in November the world watch and shock as
the floor fell out from under Sam
bankman freed over the course of just a
few days the 30 year old founder and
former CEO of cryptocurrency exchange
FTX went from one of the 50 richest
people in America to the poster boy of
the biggest crypto collapse to date as
FTX collapsed bankman freed lost an
estimated 17 billion dollars making it
one of the biggest billionaire blow-ups
of all time few other billionaires have
fallen so far so fast but bankman freed
isn't the only billionaire this year who
lost a fortune seemingly overnight
earlier this year Forbes estimated that
Kanye West who now legally goes by the
name yay was worth about two billion
dollars but after a slew of anti-Semitic
comments and other controversial
behavior and interviews and online
West's biggest partner Adidas which
worked with his Yeezy line of sneakers
canceled the contract that they had with
him and that removed about 1.5 billion
dollars from his net worth according to
forbes's estimates he's still worth an
estimated 400 million dollars from some
other assets including his music catalog
some personal real estate and a stake in
his ex-wife Kim Kardashian's shapewear
company skims another founder who lost
their billions following the failure of
their company is Elizabeth Holmes
Elizabeth Holmes founded the blood
testing company theranos and she was
valued at 4.5 billion dollars at her
peak in 2015 by investors over the
course of the next year that Came
Crashing Down when it became clear that
the technology she claimed theranos had
allegedly able to do diagnostic tests
from just a couple of drops of blood
from a prick of the fingertip didn't
really exist and so by the next year her
net worth had dropped to zero dollars
and she was sentenced to 11 years in
prison in late November for defrauding
investors but of course Holmes and yay
aren't the only billionaire blow-ups
caused by personal wrongdoing AK Batista
was at one point the richest person in
Brazil worth an estimated 30 billion
dollars he was the head of ebx group
which was a oil and gas conglomerate a
year after his fortune peaked in 2012
the company began to miss on some of its
production deadlines and it was later
revealed that he had vastly overstated
their oil reserved and general
production capacity he was sentenced to
30 years in prison in 2018 for bribing
the former Governor of of Rio De Janeiro
in exchange for State contracts and he
is currently serving out that sentence
under house arrest in his Mansion
according to a source
Alan Stanford ran one of the biggest
Ponzi schemes in history he competes
with but he made off for that title he
was convicted in 2012 for running a
seven billion dollar Ponzi scheme
through his
texas-based company Stanford Financial
Group and he was sentenced to 110 years
in prison in 2012 for those crimes and
some billionaires have been brought down
by forces outside their control like
Mikhail kortikovsky Mikhail kodakovsky
was at one point believed to be the
richest man in Russia he ran the private
oil Giant yukos and was worth an
estimated 15 billion dollars at his peak
in 2004 but after a public sparring with
Russian President Vladimir Putin he was
charged with fraud and thrown in jail
for 10 years claims that he vehemently
denies he is now a pro-democracy
activist and he has been exiled and
lives in in the UK yukos was later
dismantled and sold for pots and
absorbed by the state-controlled oil
Giant rosineft